el ejército ruso ha atacado la ciudad
portuaria de odessa dos misiles han
impactado contra un edificio de
viviendas y un edificio militar hay
cinco fallecidos o de esa es una ciudad
clave para este país apenas había sido
atacada tiene más de 800 mil habitantes
y es muy significativo este lanzamiento
de misiles porque se produce horas
después de que un alto cargo militar
ruso avisara de que odessa está bajo el
punto de mira porque quieren controlar
todo ese flanco sur el ministro de
exteriores culé va denunciado que estos
ataques forman parte de una campaña para
aterrorizar a todos los ciudadanos de
este país de forma simultánea también ha
sido atacado la ciudad de kharkiv que es
frente de batalla y a quién ni pero
dónde nos encontramos las defensas
antiaéreas se han derribado un misil
justo en el parque que tenemos a
nuestras espaldas donde han caído los
fragmentos a esa hora el parque estaba
abierto